[Música]
crecen los contagios de kobe 19 entre el
círculo más cercano del mandatario-
donald trump el turno ahora es para el
asesor de la casa blanca y stephen
miller pese a esto el mandatario prevé
participar en el próximo debate
presidencial sin cumplir la cuarentena
su rival joe biden le ha dicho que el
virus no es una arma política
considerado como el más peligroso
huracán de los últimos años en el
sureste de méxico
delta tocó tierra como la tormenta de
categoría 2 extremadamente peligrosa
cerca de puerto morelos en la península
de yucatán y amenaza con lluvias de
potencial catastrófico tenemos reporte
desde mexico
como una tragedia calificó el presidente
de a rusia la guerra entre las fuerzas
armadas de azerbaiyán y armenia por el
territorio de nagorno karabaj el primer
ministro armenio acusó a turquía de ser
directamente responsable mientras tanto
el defensor del pueblo karabají calificó
los enfrentamientos como un desastre
humanitario
hola como estan buenos dias en américa
latina y a todos ustedes que nos siguen
por la señal de france 24 mi nombre es
salgan a austria sean bienvenidos y
comenzamos esta emisión en eeuu y es que
mientras donald trump ha mostrado
disposición de retomar lo más pronto
posible su campaña hacia la reelección y
prevé participar en el próximo debate
presidencial en su círculo más cercano
crecen los contagios de kobe 19 el
último caso positivo conocido es el de
stephen miller asesor principal de la
casa blanca en medio de la situación el
rival político de trump joe biden mostró
preocupación por el manejo que le está
dando trompa su contagio y afirmó que el
virus no es un arma política veamos el
siguiente informe
trump ha regresado a la casa blanca tras
ser internado por su contagio de kobe 19
pero todo se tornó diferente la sala de
prensa un lugar frecuentemente lleno de
personas se muestra sin reporteros allí
se observa el personal de limpieza bajo
fuertes medidas de protección
desinfectando el área y es que los casos
entre los allegados al donald trump
siguen en aumento stephen miller uno de
los asesores del presidente fue el
último confirmado por kobe 19 trump
también informado que otros funcionarios
republicanos están afectados por la
enfermedad para el doctor anthony fauci
el brote de la casa blanca se habría
evitado con controles más estrictos y
pues nada ya no se hizo de acuerdo con
las recomendaciones es decir lo que se
vio en la casa blanca esa imagen desde
arriba con todos los aglomerados sin
máscara seccionó se hizo de acuerdo con
lo que hubiera recomendado
tras su regreso a la casa blanca- donald
trump mantiene un poderoso cóctel de
drogas como tratamiento pero ha señalado
su disposición de participar en el
próximo debate presidencial
joe biden su rival político pidió no
tomar el virus común
armand política y ha pedido a trump que
transmita el mensaje correcto sobre la
enfermedad
en lugar de hablar lo único que escuché
fue un tweet que decía no te preocupes
por todo esto hay mucho de qué
preocuparse 210 mil personas han muerto
respecto al debate sostiene que este
evento debe cancelarse dato el contagio
del presidente
y seguimos con noticias estadounidenses
pues el gobierno de donald trump
endureció los requisitos para aprobar
una futura vacuna contra el cob y 19 la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos publicó una guía con los
nuevos requisitos entre ellos el hacer
seguimiento durante al menos dos meses a
los voluntarios tras aplicarles la dosis
final durante la fase de prueba esto
podría retrasar la salida al mercado de
las actuales candidatas
y espere esta noche a partir de las 20
horas bogota ciudad de mexico quito y
lima la transmisión y análisis del
debate de los candidatos a la
vicepresidencia de eeuu
la demócrata kamala harris y el
republicano y actual vicepresidente mike
pence se miden en su primer y único
debate electoral desde la ciudad de show
lake city en el estado de yura en un
contexto de diferencias sobre las
medidas de protección frente al cob y 19
después de que el mandatario donald
trump diera positivo la semana pasada
en otros temas del está tocó tierra como
tormenta de categoría 2 extremadamente
peligrosas cerca de puerto morelos en la
península mexicana de yucatán al
acercarse a tierra delta disminuyó
ligeramente su velocidad pero amenaza
con tormentas de potencial catastrófico
horas antes los aeropuertos de cancún
uno de los principales destinos
turísticos de méxico y de cozumel
quedaron cerrados se han evacuado miles
de turistas en mexico en cuba unas
14.000 personas fueron evacuadas el
huracán es el más peligroso que quintana
roo ha recibido en 15 años así lo
advirtió el gobernador del estado
mexicano carlos joaquín gonzález es por
ello que enlazamos con el corresponsal
de france 24 en ciudad de méxico buenos
dias por allá en la capital mario
carbonell háblanos de cómo se han
preparado las autoridades para recibir
el impacto de delta
buen día pues desde ayer a la una de la
tarde se suspendieron todas las labores
no esenciales en quintana roo y a las 5
de la tarde también las esenciales de
excepto las de salud y seguridad 35 mil
turistas en quintana roo fueron puestas
a resguardo en todos los puntos
turísticos cancún isla mujeres cozumel o
la isla de holbox fue totalmente
evacuada 4.000 personas fueron llevadas
a los albergues también el centro de
convenciones de la ciudad de cancún se
habilitó como refugio para todas las
personas que habitan en la zona hotelera
y que consideran que sus domicilios no
son seguros también se desplegaron 5.000
elementos tanto del ejército como de la
marina-armada de méxico y la guardia
nacional para brindar apoyo a la
población que lo requiera se cerraron
como ya lo mencionaba los aeropuertos y
por supuesto también los cruces
marítimos los ferrys entre la isla de
cozumel y de isla mujeres con cancún y
con playa del carmen también en el
yucatán se tomaron las previsiones
medida estaba dispuesta para
y nueve mil turistas de quintana roo que
no hubieran conseguido lugar allá y
también por supuesto los pobladores de
las zonas costeras de yucatán fueron
llevados a resguardo algunos refugios en
san felipe en el río lagartos y en el
cuy o en los hospitales también las
áreas cobit por ejemplo del hospital
jesús combate que estaba pues instalada
con carpas en la parte exterior todos
los pacientes fueron llevados al
interior del edificio para tomar las
precauciones se vivieron algunas compras
de pánico desde la tarde de las personas
que fueron a conseguir víveres para pues
tomar sus precauciones esto entre otras
medidas a la mar yo nos quedan 40
segunditos con qué fuerza e impacto
tierra delta y hacia dónde se dirige
bien pues desde las 530 tocó tierra como
ya lo mencionaba con fuertes vientos que
van sostenidos desde 175 km hy rachas de
hasta 205 kilómetros por hora ya había
algunas palmeras derribadas en cancún se
sienten ya los efectos de este huracán 2
se dirige hacia cancún en las próximas
horas en el transcurso de la mañana
serán los momentos más difíciles también
en yucatán y se prevé que hacia después
del mediodía avance ya hacia el golfo de
méxico pues transcurso el desplazamiento
es a una buena velocidad por lo que no
se prevé que dure mucho tiempo sobre
tierra mexicana muy bien mario carbonell
muchas gracias por tu reporte nuestro
corresponsal de france 24 en mexico y
vamos ahora a otros temas y es que el
premio nobel de química fue otorgado
este miércoles a las científicas emanuel
charpentier y jennifer dona por
reescribir el código de la vida y el
desarrollo de un método para la edición
del genoma así lo anunció la academia
sueca de ciencias en estocolmo la
francesa y la estadounidense
descubrieron
de las herramientas más afiladas de la
tecnología genética las tijeras
genéticas crispe r9 con las que los
investigadores pueden cambiar el adn de
animales plantas y microorganismos con
una precisión extremadamente alta el
premio de química es el último entre los
premios científicos de la ronda de los
nobel tras haberse revelado el lunes el
de medicina y ayer martes el de física
mañana se anunciará el correspondiente a
la literatura el viernes seguirá el de
la paz y finalmente se cerrará la ronda
con el de economía el próximo jueves
nos vamos con una sentencia histórica en
grecia y es que el líder del partido
político neonazi amanecer dorado fue
acusado de dirigir una organización
criminal un grupo de jueces de atenas le
puso punto final a un proceso de más de
cinco años de litigio en donde los
miembros de la agrupación también
resultaron culpables de varios crímenes
entre estos asesinatos minutos antes de
conocer el veredicto por la céntrica
avenida aleksandras se reunieron miles
de personas con mensajes como no son
inocentes el fascismo no es una opinión
es un crimen o condenen a los nazis
en otros temas el primer ministro de
armenia acusó a turquía de ser
directamente responsable de la guerra en
nagorno karabaj donde combaten fuerzas
armenias y azerbaiyanas esto pese a los
llamados a una tregua de gran parte de
la comunidad internacional como la unión
europea-rusia cuyo presidente vladimir
putin calificó hoy de tragedia esta
guerra y pidió un alto el fuego lo antes
posible el tribunal europeo de derechos
humanos por su parte aceptó una medida
cautelar solicitada por armenia por lo
que pidió a turquía y al resto de países
involucrados abstenerse de actos que
vulneren los derechos humanos por su
parte el defensor del pueblo karabají
dijo que su región es escenario de
desastre humanitario debido a los
indiscriminados bombardeos azerbaiyanos
contra la población civil que tan
apremiante es un cese del fuego en esta
región nos respondió para france24 paulo
vota director del programa ejecutivo en
medio oriente contemporáneo de la
universidad católica argentina
en realidad ese es el fuego sería una
necesidad del problema es que no es
solamente un problema de carácter
militar sino que también involucra la
posible salida diplomática durante más
de tres décadas el proceso de paz no va
a aumentar porque el gobierno al medio
no tenía ningún incentivo para sentarse
a negociar esto es tenía los territorios
y por lo tanto no había ningún incentivo
para que se sentaran a negociar y a la
vez el proceso de paz hizo que
azerbaiyán se sintiera demasiado
frustrado con este no avance de las
negociaciones es por eso que la
situación militar hoy en día complejiza
todo porque porque ahora armenia siente
la necesidad de sentarse a negociar
mientras que azerbaiyán ha perdido el
incentivo para hacerlo creo que ahí será
en los próximos días deberemos ver como
las grandes potencias los miembros del
grupo de minsk que son la instancia
negociadora se ponen a brindarle tanto a
armenia como azerbaiyán una posible
salida diplomática
américa latina vive una jornada de
reclamo social repasamos algunas
noticias
el presidente de chile sebastián piñera
expresó su profundo respaldo al cuerpo
policial de carabineros luego de que el
viernes un agente lanzara presuntamente
a un joven a un río durante una protesta
al tiempo que condenó el suceso y pidió
una investigación exhaustiva de los
hechos esto en el marco de una protesta
contra el gobierno en la emblemática
plaza italia
en costa rica las protestas contra un
posible acuerdo del gobierno de carlos
alvarado con el fondo monetario
internacional por 1750 millones de
dólares entre en su segunda semana sin
que haya señales de un diálogo con las
autoridades permanecen los bloqueos en
decenas de carreteras en todo el país
las dominicanas se exigen nuevas medidas
legales sobre la interrupción legal del
embarazo en santo domingo decenas de
mujeres se manifestaron este martes
frente al congreso nacional para exigir
que el código penal que se encuentra en
proceso de aprobación incluye
excepciones a la penalización del aborto
en tres supuestos
y mire para finalizar considerado uno de
los grandes guitarristas de rock de
todos los tiempos
eddie van halen murió a sus 65 años el
músico estadounidense de origen irlandés
estaba en tratamiento por cáncer de
garganta
fueron estos legendarios solos de
guitarra tocados a una velocidad
asombrosa con control e innovación los
que catapultaron avance
fue uno de los veinte artistas más
vendidos de todos los tiempos
la banda fue introducida en el hall de
la fama del rock and roll en 2007 eddie
van halen nació en amsterdam países
bajos en una familia de músicos que
emigraron a california en 1962 10 años
después fundó la banda con su apellido
su hermano álex en la batería y david
lee roth como vocalista pronto se
convirtieron en la banda de california
que esperaba sacar a la música disco de
las listas y para potenciar su vida de
rock and roll estuvieron los cócteles de
cigarrillos alcohol y drogas duras desde
que era joven todo pasó factura en la
salud de eddie van halen
tengo una cirugía de reemplazo de cadera
programada para diciembre 16 pero
depende de donde estemos en nuestro
proceso de grabación
quizás espere a enero pero no podemos
irnos de tour bueno yo puedo sentarme a
tocar no importa sabes no creo que la
gente venga a ver como me deslizo en mis
rodillas o como brinco
[Música]
luego de su cirugía de cadera en 1999 le
removieron parte de su lengua en el 2000
tras ser diagnosticado con un cáncer una
enfermedad que volvió en sus últimos
años sus tributos se han hecho para
honrar a uno de los más grandes músicos
mientras que su hijo lo describe como el
mejor papá que pudo haber tenido y dice
que los momentos que compartieron fuera
del escenario son un regalo
pues así llegamos al final de esta
emisión les agradecemos mucho su
compañía los invitamos a que sigan con
las noticias en france24 ya que se cuide
cuídese mucho del cómic 19
[Música]